let's go next to the 2:8 one area code
who's calling today from 281 hey
Jonathan what's up I'm just wondering if
you personally would ever consider going
vegan okay and I am NOT considering that
right now and it's conceivable that at
some other point I would consider a
change to my diet but I'm pretty happy
with my diet right now and I plan to
stick with it
yeah that makes sense
I was just wondering because I mean I
know that like I think the statistic is
sub 71% of emissions come from only a
hundred companies right so your personal
decision like going vegan I don't know
how much change that would really make
entire thing why there's a couple
different things here and we don't have
to did this will piss everybody off and
we don't have to adjudicate it
I believe that agricultural emissions
are about 11 percent of American
emissions and of course there is no
doubt that factory animal farming is a
large portion of that within factory
animal farming I believe that it's cows
and sheep are a disproportionately large
portion of that the issue is there's a
few different things one for grass-fed
free-range animals when you look at crop
rotation and the way in which animals if
they are cycled on to pastures actually
start generating through their excrement
for lack of a better term a lot of
really good bacteria and soil
revitalization there's some interesting
studies that show that at the small
scale it's actually good for the
environment in terms of recycling the
same land so that it can be productively
used over time sustainably that if you
get rid of animals altogether that that
actually could be
bad for the environment and that's very
different than you know this mass
factory farming or whatever so these
things are never that cut and dry you
know a lot of people who don't eat
animal products disproportionately eat
things like almonds and avocado and both
of those consume an a crazy amount of
water per output nutrient and lead to
the deaths of all sorts of little
animals that live in small streams and
and and little ponds and so forth so I
basically reject any of these black and
white approaches to these issues these
issues are just significantly more
complicated than most sort of dogmatists
want to accept and I want to I want to
really figure out the gray area yes
that's fascinating it's a brilliant
distinction as usual mr. Backlund okay
thank you for the answer yeah yeah we're
good all right appreciate the phone call
thank you very much okay that is all the
time I have today thank you to everyone
who called in sorry I wasn't able to get
to everybody that is always the case but
it is great that there are more people
who want to call in we will take phone
calls again we'll take a quick break and
I will answer your questions coming up
next